exactly
the moment we've all
wait is finally over
get everybody go with it we're looking
for guys who are physically mentally and
emotionally strong enough to be in this
business and to potentially be a world
champion someday
you
Dayna first of all thank you so much for
joining us today I wanted to kick things
off back in around ten twelve years ago
back in 2001
so stages you and your partners decide
to buy UFC forward we're talking around
two million dollars the company at that
time not doing so well not making money
in fact probably losing money so what
what the hell were you thinking to
actually buy this and what what kind of
plans did you have to turn things around
yeah the way that it went down was I was
managing fighters at that time chuck and
tito ortiz and i had found out in
contract negotiations with the old owner
of the UFC that they were going out of
business so my partners and I were
looking to get involved in boxing at
that time and I called them up and said
these guys are in big trouble they're
losing money I think we can buy it and a
month later we own the company
and the reason was we started taking
jiu-jitsu and that's how I started to
manage Tito and Chuck and then we
started to meet a lot of these fighters
and we were blown away by him we were
you know these guys were really smart I
mean Chuck Liddell's kind of from this
area you know what I mean
I mean everybody in here knows who Chuck
Liddell is right that's a stupid
question I figured that so if you look
at Chuck Liddell right and if you think
about to the mainstream you know when we
first started doing this Chuck Liddell
is if you wanted to know what an
ultimate fighter looks like he's the guy
he's got the mohawk he's got Chinese
writing down the side of his head he's
mean-looking the guy the guy graduated
from Cal Poly with honors with an
accounting degree what you know any I
just makes no sense it doesn't when you
started looking at these guys I said if
these guys were marketed the right way
this thing could really work the other
thing that that I always truly believed
and back you know 12 years ago people
thought I was crazy was that this would
work everywhere all over the planet
because if you look at the way
traditional sports work for instance in
this country the NFL there's nothing
bigger than the NFL it's huge
and I don't care if people didn't watch
one football game all season everybody
watches the Super Bowl right in India
Creek it's huge
I don't know about you but I don't give
a [ __ ] about cricket you know what I
mean and then in soccer is big all over
the world it's not that big here and the
list goes on and on of sports that work
in other countries and don't work in
other countries though one thing that I
believe worked would work everywhere is
fighting because it doesn't matter what
color you are what country you come from
what language you speak we're all human
beings and Fighting's in our DNA man we
get it and we like it and thank God I
was right
so the UFC has been without question one
of the most remarkable growth stories
for sports for the past decade so I mean
what are two or three that the main key
decisions you think that drove that are
even a couple of milestones um well how
many people here have actually been to a
UFC event have been to a live event
thank you and and you know I'm a little
biased but I truly believe I've been to
other sporting events it's the most
exciting live sporting event you will
ever see it is so exciting and so fun
live there's so much energy and so much
buzz inside that arena and I truly
believe that that the live event is what
helped us get to get to this level and
I've never had a situation even back in
the old days when nobody wanted
understand this when we first bought
this company we bought a company that
wasn't allowed on pay-per-view porn is
on pay-per-view this was not allowed on
pay-per-view our goal is to buy it and
get it on free television people thought
that that was insane and but that's the
the uphill battle that we had to fight
when we bought this company venues did
not want the UFC at their arena we would
never allow that at our arena the
actually a lot of people don't know this
but the first guy who gave us a break
when we bought the company was Donald
Trump Donald Trump the first fight we
ever had was at the Trump Taj Mahal and
he showed up for the first fight when I
say the first fight I mean the first
prelim fight and stayed til the main
event
and we had another event there and then
even when we left his arena he still
showed up at the when we did it at the
Meadowlands he came to the fights and
when we did the big Fox deal there was a
big write-up in the New York Times and
Donald Trump sent me the New York Times
and said congrats brother I always knew
you were going to do it you know so I
always respected him and thought that
was really cool to him I'll never hear
me say [ __ ] about Donald Trump I talked
about everybody you'll never hear me say
anything bad about Donald
so you mentioned the whole aspect of
regulation and I mean when you forget
first started there were a lot of
politicians who wanted to get you by
guys banned in states I mean federally
you know saying saying this was human
cockfighting so the fact that you're
basically now in almost every state
except say two or three how do you guys
actually manage to get that through well
realistically it started with Senator
John McCain and he was right what he was
saying was right it wasn't wrong what
McCain was saying back in the day is and
this is how the old UFC fell apart said
what are you doing you can't go put on
fights that aren't regulated by the
Athletic Commission you can't just run
around and put on unregulated fights and
the old order of the UFC said I'll do
whatever you wanted though I want to do
you can't tell me what to do so this guy
would go to Alabama Puerto Rico places
where there was no Athletic Commission
let me tell you what gang and believe me
when I say this because I've said this
before publicly the internet all the
guys in the internet are going oh yeah
trust me when I say this I've been in
business for a long time you can't mess
with the government you can't tell the
government you're not going to do what
they would they want you to do see what
happens see how long you're in business
and now for how much fun you're having
so what we did was we did the exact
opposite we ran toward regulation we
went to these to these State athletic
commissions and said this is a real
sport these guys are real athletes it
was marketed a different way but and not
that not to smash the old owner of the
UFC but when you really think about how
this thing was created these television
guys got together and said let's put on
an event where it's style against style
what a karate guy be - kung fu guy what
a wrestler beat a boxer it was supposed
to be one event they put on this event
and it did such big pay-per-view numbers
that rivaled the WWE and boxing at the
time so you're damn right they were put
on another event and another one after
that and another one after that but what
the guy never saw and I don't think he
really realized that till too late was
he created a sport and the answer to
that age-old question of which fighting
style is the best is none are you had to
have a little piece of everything to be
a complete fighter and Bruce Lee was
preaching that back in the 60s and it
really it changed everything
martial arts evolved more since the
beginning of the UFC than they have in
the last 10,000 years I know there's
some wrestlers
and here from from the wrestling team
today I mean if you look at what it's
done for for wrestlers
you know guys wrestled through high
school college and their goal is to
someday make it to the Olympics and if
you do then what same thing with Ronda
Rousey and juda and judo you know you're
seeing a lot of these these people who
have been competitive athletes their
whole life now have a career because the
UFC and and add a little bit more to
their repertoire and in the martial arts
field it's actually really cool
but wrestling I'm sure those questions
going to come up today but about saving
wrestling in the Olympics just had a big
meeting last week what's up with some
big guys in the wrestling community and
we're going to try to get it done it
would be terrible to see that that
martial art go away so you touched a bit
on UFC coming to rival numbers they say
WWE boxing back in the day why do you
think that that UFC has skyrocketed
while professional boxing has arguably
been in decline is fundamentally
differences in the sports or just
management or was just people think I'm
full of it but I swear to God 15 years
ago I told my partners I said boxing
going to start taking a scared and what
happened was I spent a lot of years in
the amateurs and the problem the amateur
level of boxing was dirtier than the
pros it was it was terrible then what
ended up happening was USA boxing the
body that used to govern the amateur
boxing sold it to a private company and
it just completely fell apart the
amateurs fell apart if things fall apart
at an amateur level
you're not going to be creating new
talent and I saw that coming so I told
these guys I think boxing is in big
trouble this is the right thing that's
the right time you know when we bought
the UFC you know you have a great idea
and it seems like the right time but is
it really is the timing really there
that you never know until you dive in
and start doing it cool so at this point
why don't we take a few questions from
the audience the relationship with Fox I
know it was intended to kind of catapult
the the sport into the mainstream and it
definitely got off to a rocky start
according to some people in the media
can you catch a relationship with them
yeah
to people to people on the outside it
looks like the Fox deal was a rocky
start but it was the furthest thing from
it we were actually really close to
doing a deal with another network we're
literally on the one-yard line in the
last minute Fox came in and Fox was the
deal that I always wanted and we did it
so fast and these guys did such a
fantastic job of what we have is a lot
of content we needed to get our content
out there and they spread our content
across all their platforms and I said if
you look back to interviews when we did
the Fox deal I said the next two years
are more important than the last 10
years of work that we've done and we
have a lot of work to do in these next
few years with this Fox deal and we did
it the first year we're in this thing a
year and a half and things couldn't be
better right now these guys were amazing
and they're young they're smart and
they're aggressive and if anybody in
here is even considering getting into
the television business you want to work
for Fox I've been in the TV business for
a long time most of these guys are
pompous arrogant jackasses that you
would never want to work for trust me
you didn't go through college to go work
for some of these guys you want to work
for the guys at Fox they're great guys I
hope I stayed with them forever because
I'll never get another television deal
I want to talk about some of the other
companies that are trying to get up in
the game and and you've seen a lot of
them fail as well or UFC buy them out
what do you think are some of the key
ingredients in the UFC versus other
companies that are getting it that
global well what's funny is for people
you that don't know what he's talking
about he's talking about competitors
he's talking about guys that have seen
if you look back six years ago money was
growing on trees anybody could get a
loan you can pick up the phone and
anybody could get a loan for anything
business house cars it was easy to raise
money so you know we go out there we
make this thing work the first season of
The Ultimate Fighter happens is think
skyrockets starts to take off so of
course the fight business is a fun
business to be in so everybody starts
diving to this thing well it's easy
right just throw three letters together
and buy a cage and put on fights anybody
could do that so these guys go out and
the biggest mistake that everybody makes
when they try to compete with us is they
try to compete with us first of all we
didn't come out yesterday and put
together an organization and now we're
on Fox and now our on pay-per-view
anything you do nothing nothing is
nothing happens overnight man it's it
seems that way but it's all hard work I
have been on planes trains and
automobiles for the last 13 years
outselling the sport getting deals done
getting door slammed on my face you name
it it's all happened and these guys come
out and they just start throwing money
around and start trying to be the UFC
don't try to be the UFC the first thing
you have to do when you start a business
is know exactly who you are and what is
your game plan you know
what are we going to do first first year
is your is where you're looking what are
we going to do first year you make it
through that first year and you're still
alive all right what's our 3-year plan
you get into your 3-year plan and that's
how you start to build your company the
last thing on this is how stupid it is
okay be like we're all sitting around to
my living room we're all here we're
hanging out in my living room and we're
watching NASCAR okay holy [ __ ] look at
all the people at NASCAR these guys must
be making tons of money you know what we
should do we should go get a couple
other drivers
and let's start our own race League and
we'll compete with NASCAR anybody want
to jump in with me
hell no you know it sounds like the
stupidest idea ever but people think
they can do it with the UFC UFC has been
around for 20 years 20 years and this
November it will be 13 years for us and
you think you're going to just dive
right in and start throwing money around
you will go out of business so fast now
Bellator you guys know Bellator they
started on this is a different scenario
they're owned by Viacom so a lot of
these hardcore fans that you see on the
internet start talking about yeah I hope
Bellator kicks their ass and I hope
they're there there's a small guy
there's a small guy it's Viacom one of
the largest media companies in the world
I'm the small guy it's insane did I ask
you a question all right I start going
off like a wild man you got a real me
back in over a dana of a vague source
well the first year so back a little
more includes point if Strikeforce is
gone
pride is gone you don't have many
competitors what worries you about the
future of UFC and let me say something
else too when people say that oh they
went in and they they bought pride they
bought Strikeforce
they bought this they bought that you
see anybody buying us because we're not
in trouble
we didn't just go hey listen we don't
want these guys to compete against us
let's buy them how does that work you
can't buy us we got a plan we you know
we've got a goal we know what we're
doing right go talk to the guys who own
Strikeforce and ask if they're pissed
off that we bought them those guys were
in the hole a lot of money and we came
in and bought it
we saw some value there library um well
I mean just look at what's happened with
Diaz the fight that we did with Diaz
just one guy if you look at what we paid
for Strikeforce and one guy what we did
with that fight and if you look at the
purchase of Pride the library you guys
see that all over TV we're doing the
best of Pride and all this stuff and
then you see because I saw somebody I
keep talking about the internet internet
drives me crazy so they're saying you
know it was the most expensive
fight librarian history you're an idiot
the guy who wrote that if you look at
the talent that we've had from Pride and
how many fights we've done huge massive
fights that have made tons of revenue
and helped build our library pride and
strike force were both great purchases
so is the WC did I answer your question
you asked me about competition
competition um so you asked me a
question do I think that uh not having
competition hurts me it's it's not even
about what I do need is I need other I
need other organizations I'm not out
trying to kill other organizations the
only time you've ever seen me act like I
wanted to kill an organization was guys
who came out and talked smack about us
those were the really the times it was
like I you want to fight we'll fight but
as far as I need all these other
organizations to not only exist but to
make money and and to do well because
what they really do is and nobody ever
wants to look at themselves as a feeder
League to the UFC deal with it you're
all feeder leagues to the UFC okay and I
want them to exist and make money
because those guys create the next
talent that will end up in our
organization someday um but as far as
competition if somebody starts to get to
that level what are you going to do you
know good for them they have the right
business model and there's actually a
company in Africa right now of all
places
there's a company in Africa that is
kicking some ass and they're doing
really well they have the right model in
the doing it right they're not out
trying to be us and they're making money
and they're doing very well let me take
one more from this general over here hi
thanks for making it today my question
is about the talent pipeline to mention
briefly amateur boxing what about
amateur MMA how how did you plan develop
this pipeline nationally and
internationally
the follow-up questions on the LMA in
the Olympics so you mention about saving
wrestling but what about MMA in the
Olympics and being a potential pipeline
for international talent in light of the
recent developments and wrestling and
boxing etc and Olympics yeah what was
your first question talent pipeline yeah
Thailand pipeline nationally
internationally and second questions on
Olympics and a Nightline what like
talent pipeline how you develop are you
going to how are you ensure that there
is a talent right so right now there is
in the country in the world where fights
aren't happening all over the world
fights are happening every weekend and
new talent is being created in markets
that we've just gone into like China
we're going into India and Mexico what
we do is we go in there first and we
have Scouts that go in and Scout talent
we have guys go out and round up all the
talent and then we start training these
guys we get it set up to where these
guys can start training and the goal is
to do Ultimate Fighter in every country
in Brazil 11 million people watch The
Ultimate Fighter every week in Brazil
when we do a fight 65 million people
watch the fight there's only 200 million
people in the country that's crazy
when you start talking about India and
China in India there's 300 million males
18 to 34 and I think they're going to
like us once we get on TV and in China
it's it's mind-boggling you know it's
just there's so many people the region
when you look at India India has a lot
of wrestling big wrestling background in
India China they started martial arts
it's been around forever so all these
places make sense the one thing going
back then I'll answer your other
question a minute but going back to when
I was telling you about how fighting
works everywhere think about this think
about the most famous athletes in the
world right and if you think about the
first one that comes to mind for me
probably most of you is Michael Jordan
Michael Jordan is known as the greatest
basketball player ever right in football
it's tough to say I'm a Patriots fan so
I'll say Tom Brady you know if you start
talking about who is the most famous
athlete all
well hockey you got somebody I'm sure
and cricket has somebody I've never
heard of him but you know soccer has
somebody and all these other sports have
their guy what's the one sport I mean
you don't know who is it can anybody in
here tell me who the best cricket player
ever was huh all right one guy that's
him there we go
anybody else we got two guys two guys
that can say it right you guys obviously
have lived in India or do something else
up to do with India right
am I wrong am I wrong how about hockey
does anybody know who the most famous
hockey player is Gretzky and more people
knew that than I wanted to know all
right
so but here's the reality globally
worldwide no matter what country you go
- everybody knows Mike Tyson
everybody knows Muhammad Ali everybody
knows Bruce Lee does anybody in this
room not know Bruce Lee yeah he died in
the 70s and everybody in this room knows
who he is and the list goes on and on
the one thing that everybody knows
globally worldwide is who the best
fighters in the world war anybody in
here not know Manny Pacquiao nope you
get where on the ball I'm going here it
works everywhere man because it's human
beings we're fascinated by the toughest
dude in the world
we're fascinated by it you know the
weirdest thing is I've been it fights
where a fight breaks out over here and
everybody's checking out the fight over
here we were just so fascinated by
fighting and who the tough if Mike Tyson
walked in here right now it all [ __ ]
your pants
he'd be like little kids it's crazy how
you get around these these guys who are
concerned you know considered the
toughest guys in the world and that's
why this thing works everywhere the
second part of your question was on the
Olympics the Olympics yeah actually so
so I said this about run I have every
you know wrestler on earth trying to
kill me
about two months ago because I made a
statement about wrestling that I said
listen as the world's economic problems
get deeper and deeper you know it's
about making money
and wrestling although it might be the
most exciting sport in the world to you
guys the rest of the world's a little
tough to watch you don't understand it
you don't know who's winning or losing
and it's about making exciting and
that's one of the things that I talked
about when these guys came out and
talked to me about helping them save
wrestling in the Olympics and I've never
I've never wrestled I don't know
anything about it but let me tell you
what my one of my favorite movies of all
time is Vision Quest innovating is one
of my favorite movies ever I've watched
that movie 250,000 times and never
wrestled the day in my life so there's
something to that in making wrestling a
little more exciting and making people
want to watch it and I do think that
mixed martial arts would work because it
is exciting and as far as amateur MMA
goes I hate it I hate amateur MMA
because what it means today there's no
such thing as amateur MMA so all these
guys who start amateur MMA what it
really means is I don't have to pay the
fighters I can put on an event and I
don't have to pay the talent I hate it
hope I answered your question
cool did you have a question let's yeah
let's go a little one I'm taking over
here no worries man sorry it's a this
guy is Andre hmm
versus another over time it has become
more professionalized more of a martial
art right well it's not as interesting
anymore yeah because of this lack of
factor of uncertainty the knockout
cannoneer the mix of you know it's very
technical now how do you think about
this factor and you know how it impacts
the audience and whatnot and kind of
relates also maybe you know John Fitch
being caught right like where he is not
an exciting fighter like so what are you
doing - what would cut for not being an
exciting fighter so yeah it's not not
exactly I was real with you but that's
not why it was called so how do you
think about making it more exciting less
of you know point fighting how some guys
are doing it now and more of a
traditional where guys go all out is it
you know getting given the bonuses okay
you know kind of how you think about
making it order was originally yeah and
the uncertainty factor versus just point
fighting if you don't think the UFC is
exciting you got to be a lunatic okay I
don't know what you are you want to see
people get beat with baseball bats you
know I mean first of all that that
generation of people that think that
that you know oh I want the
no-holds-barred no rules it's that big
this many people want to see a freak
show this many people want to see a real
sport huge difference so the market the
market of people that are like valet to
toe and we want the whole all the know
rules and all that stuff and I got to be
honest with you the old hold no rules
and [ __ ] wasn't very exciting you know
what I mean it really wasn't um
and what we try to do is we keep trying
to push the sport to be more and more so
you have to understand what my job is
what my job is in this day and age how
old are you
you're 27 I'm 43 okay when I grew up
there was channel 3 channel 5 channel 8
and channel 13 okay if you called me I
had to be home to answer the phone
because we don't have answering machines
any of that stuff right so this day and
age if you want to see some crazy [ __ ]
go on YouTube type in any crazy [ __ ] you
want and 50 other crazy shits will come
up on the other side that you can watch
for three days right you go the movies
you can go here you can do this that you
can do there's a tons of things you can
do I have to convince you to stay home
on Saturday now always stay home on
Saturday when you've been busting your
ass at school all week working all the
other things you got to do you probably
want to go out and you know meet some
girls or take your girl out to dinner or
go to a movie I compete with all these
things
basketballs on footballs on you know
what I mean all this other stuff that
goes on I have to convince you to stay
home on Saturday and pay $55 to watch my
event that's what I have to do that's
that's my job in this business and when
you stay home get all your buddies
together and you sit around and you buy
my fight for $55 you better be
entertained because if you're not you're
how hard it's going to be for me to get
you the next time I have an event it's
not going to be easy but that is what I
do for a living I put together fights
that are compelling enough to make you
stay home on a Saturday night and pay
$55 for it you understand what I'm
saying when I agree with that
I just meant like in terms ofyou know
lay and pray style right we're thinking
about changing some of the rules you're
changing the incentives of the fighters
to worry no there is no situation where
a guy want two rounds and in the third
round he just runs away and legs awaken
how do you think about making them more
engaged and actually putting
unfortunately I am in a business where
we just talked about how this thing
evolved the State Athletic Commission
they they have the referees the referees
that's why you you will never hear
anybody talk more smack about referees
than me
you know they will let these guys stand
against the fence the rule is you're
either doing damage or advancing your
position or the fight has to be split up
and started over again and it drives me
insane when that doesn't happen you know
but the thing that we do different than
any other sport especially boxing when
you think about boxing right they do the
same thing and how many guys in here
whose boxing fans I am I'll raise my
hand ooh okay like five-year and make
but here's the thing that
did and the question was asked earlier
on the decline of boxing well what would
happen was the fight would be coming
it's a week away and I'm so excited I
can't wait I'm watching everything I'm
reading everything that leads up to the
fight right it's night of the fight I
got all my buddies over we bought all
the beats and the beer we're ready to
roll and a fight never happens these
guys run around for 12 rounds and the
fight doesn't happen do you know why you
know why this has happened and why
boxing is dying because the sport has
become so greedy nobody was ever
thinking about the future of the sport
it's about how much money can we all put
in our pocket right here right now
who cares about tomorrow so essentially
what you get at the end is you get to
multimillionaires right who step into
the ring and do everything they can to
avoid a fight so they can win just
barely win to get to the next
multi-million dollar fight that we pay
for right and it just became ridiculous
and it's exactly what goes think about
this think about every person in this
room right now if I guaranteed you all
37 million dollars guaranteed it
guarantees 37 million dollars this year
guess what you're going to do not much
not much I'm going to bust your ass
every day your alarms going to go off in
the morning going I'm not going to go to
class hell do I want to go to class for
I got 37 million dollars
right who's going to class if they got
37 million dollars nobody's going to
class you know what happens when you get
37 million dollars in your fighter I
don't want to get punched in the face
I got 37 million dollars man not getting
punched in the face is ridiculous we
incentivize guys to fight you're going
to you get you get money to show and you
get money to win and then you get money
for the best fight of the night you get
money for the best knockout money for
the best submission you're incentivized
no different than any other business in
the world show up at your job and have a
half-assed day see how that goes
now I'm not in the mood today see I see
how that goes you have to be
incentivized when somebody hires you
when you guys leave this school and go
to these other jobs you will cut out a
deal where you're working for some big
company where you'll have incentives and
bonuses it's the way the real world
works
boxing does not live in the real world
anymore and that's why it's hurting so I
want to switch gears real quick Dennis
so it seems that often times you've been
misquoted or misunderstood on your
stance towards female fighters
understood for sure but can you kind of
talk us through your choice to actually
have female headliners for UFC 157 and
yes this something started something
newer you know what's the deal good
question so ah he's saying women's
fighting I used to be the guy that said
never it'll never happen in the UFC
sorry ladies the reason that I said that
was two weren't enough talented girls
fighting to create an entire division
and I will tell you this and this comes
off sexist sometimes but I swear to god
I'm not sexist but I think it's just the
the I think it's the feeling of all men
in this country and it really hit me
about eleven years ago I saw a fight up
here in Northern California was up here
somewhere and two girls fought in the
card okay one girl fought just like
Randy Couture and look just like Randy
Couture
and another girl beautiful girl looked
like she took about four taibo classes
and it was one of the worst beatings I
have ever seen and I was just like
there's no way in hell and for me in the
brand and the business you put a
mismatch between men on TV and people
are like little is this this this is bad
you put a mismatch between women on TV
that's tough to bounce back from it's
tough to recover from Ronda Rousey so
everybody know who Ronda Rousey is so I
saw some of her fights I met her one
night at a UFC event we ended up talking
and she blew me away you know she's
beautiful she's smart but she is a Diez
brother inside believe me when I tell
you she is a fighter and she is mean and
she is nasty
so we started doing some research on 135
pound of vision that she was in and
there were talented girls there and the
fight that really put me over the edge
and got me to say okay was the Miesha
Tate fight when she fought me she paid
and and I said I did it you know I just
said you know what now might be the time
we know we've got four good fights for
her lined up and everybody took me
saying that is like oh she's definitely
gonna win and there's four or five do we
got four or five anything could happen
Liz Carmouche definitely could have won
that fight you know and I was telling
the guys earlier the biggest fight in
women's fighting history was Laila Ali
versus Frazier daughter they did 120,000
buys and the Liz Carmouche Ronda Rousey
fight blew that out of the water by far
the biggest women's fight ever in the
history of fighting so it was the right
decision
cool it worked out nice I mean you also
said a bunch of times that you develop
personal I mean you basically develop
friendships whether
with a bunch of your fighters right and
so how have you dealt with fighters who
have missed showing up for promo events
fighters who have even failed drug tests
I mean what I mean that must be some
kind of tension for your back you know
there's times where I get mad at guys I
get mad and we battle and um but it's
all business it's business
I mean you've also come out fairly or
you have seen general has kind of taken
a strong stance on the use of TRT the
testosterone replacement therapy over
over time so I mean I was cool with it
in the beginning yeah you know when you
look at it it's science
you know they found a way for guys as
guys start to age and bring your
testosterone levels up um but again like
everything else in life people start
abusing it so if this much gets me up to
where I'm supposed to be where does this
much get me right this much makes you
not even human anymore that's what this
much does and it's and it's unfair some
of the two takeaways so far from this
conversation has been strategy and
planning once the UFC makes that global
saturation there in all the continents
in the world
everyone's watching where does the UFC
want to take their vision in their focus
well our goal when we when we started
this company was to build a sport and to
build a sport everybody plays by the
same rules all over the world and you
guys know what's going on in New York
you know we're still battling in New
York we're still battling and France so
there's still a lot of work to do
there's a lot of countries we're not in
right now we're in 175 countries 22
different languages and over a billion
homes worldwide on television and
there's still a lot when you really sit
down and when we get together and sit in
a room and start talking about what
needs to be done and how much more we
could do it's mind-boggling how big this
thing is going to be you know people
think it's big now we're not even close
it's like you know I'll still talk to
people that don't know what the UFC is
when people say we're mainstream now
we're still not we're getting closer
we're getting closer you know
box is a huge step in the right
direction but it's a we've still got a
lot of work to do and so when you say
once we get there I don't know if I'll
ever get there you know as long as my
career lasts
it's just there's always going to be a
battle fight the hard part is every day
when you get up no matter what business
you're in no matter what business you
guys end up in dumb [ __ ] happens every
day you know so you spend all the time
that you were supposed to be working on
the good things putting out fires and
working on the stupid stuff you know so
here's the thing if there's a lot of
sports out there that I'll give you an
example I'm a huge huge fan of surfing
love surfing and I'm a huge fan of
skating hang out with a lot of skate
guys and surf guys and actually they've
asked me to come to their having like a
World Summit this year down in Mexico
and Cabo and they want me to come try to
help them with the future of surfing um
like I get all these fringe sports now
that try to get me to come help them
figure out how to how to build their
business and here's the problem the
problem that a lot of these French
sports have like if you ever anybody
here in surfing right okay
so if you who surfs do you okay so if if
you go right if you go and watch guys
surf these waves are massive and you
hear them break and a pound and and if
you're in some place I I was in Fiji two
years ago my kids surfed in Fiji right
two years ago and we were in the boat so
these guys know how to move the boats
it's unbelievable it's one of the most
amazing things you can ever see and when
you see some of these kids that are
really good and they're riding in these
huge tubes and all this stuff I'm
telling you it is it's life-changing
it's awesome I love it now watch it on
television you don't feel that you don't
even come close to feeling that on TV
like I was cool not interesting and you
change it it does not translate onto
television okay
I'm friends with rob dyrdek Tony Hawk
Sean
white all these guys right and I see
these guys skate and and when you see
when they're inside how high they go and
the tricks that they do you're blown
away because you're standing there and
they're up there flipping and doing all
this [ __ ] right watch it on TV alright
it changes its it's not interesting it
doesn't translate well onto television
and it's just like ah the NFL and maybe
some of you might think I'm wrong on
this but just my personal experience I
love the NFL on TV it's fun to watch
exciting they got the camera angles
awesome go to a game especially if
you're a Patriots fan okay Patriots fan
you drive an hour and a half on a
one-way road right this way and this way
is it the way in to the way out bumper
to bumper you get there it's two degrees
you're sitting on metal benches I can't
see [ __ ] I got a fat guy painted blue
white and red with no shirt on sitting
next to me spilling beer on me for two
hours that is not a good experience for
me that's not fun to me you know what I
mean the one thing that the UFC has is
if you go to the live event it is
awesome it's exciting and it's
unexplainable you have to see it it's
also great on television it works in
both areas and that's one of the
problems that most sports have is
translating the live event and
translating on television you know what
I mean and that's the one thing that I
truly think we've done a great job at
and it's one of the things that I'm
absolutely psychotic about we've been
doing this thing that we do so many
fights it's almost like you're
sleepwalking you're going through it I
rehearse everything we rehearse from the
show open all the fighter walkins we go
through full-blown rehearsals because
when you spend your money to come see my
event nobody's going to make a mistake
we're going to make sure that you get
everything you paid for whether you're
there live or you're watching on
television we had a question I think
over here from this lady my question is
about your effort reference to digital
content you have a Content factory you
created all the time you are con
this lecture is content so thank you for
this thank you I'm curious about the
challenges and opportunities you see
ahead of you for your digital platform
that's a great question
really good question and any of you that
follow the UFC or would ever know that
I'm a social media lunatic I love social
media it's amazing arm and we live in a
world now where the world just keeps
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
communication just everything travels so
fast if you wanted to know what was
happening again I'm going back to my era
you had to read the paper in the morning
and catch the news at night or somebody
heard something and they tell you you
know you get on Twitter and just I mean
Twitter Facebook all these different
platforms now it's a million miles an
hour and the interesting thing is when
we first bought the UFC we weren't on
pay-per-view
right and we had to go out there and cut
deals with DirecTV Dish and in demand
pay-per-view right those were our three
distribution platforms now with the
Internet and and and and I'm still
waiting it's curious to see how this is
going to work if you look at boxing
right boxing puts on a fight let's say
it's Floyd Mayweather versus Ricky
Hatton right Ricky Hatton from the UK
some people in the UK care about the
fight and some boxing fans in the United
States care about the fight when we put
on an event or our events are so
international we do these Facebook
fights we were literally the first first
sports organization to do live-streaming
on Facebook putting the sporting of that
and we stream all over the world people
all over the world are watching our
events so as this thing continues to
grow where we can buy things through the
internet and now Google and Yahoo and
YouTube are becoming so powerful they're
actually becoming networks they're
actually becoming their own networks you
know any of you guys ever watched my
video blogs to people great so I do
these video blogs leading up to a fight
you know and these things have had
anywhere from 250,000 viewers
to a million and fuel TV you know we got
on FUEL TV with Fox fuel TV when they
and all the extreme athletes hate me
like I just all the hate mail is getting
from these extreme athletes like I
killed them on FUEL TV but they were
pulling hashtags for ratings in order
hashtag means means so fuel people were
watching
they can't even rate it and a good a
good night for them was 7,000 viewers
when they had skateboarding and surfing
and things like that on and we we broke
every record but my point was on YouTube
my videos pull better ratings than
television shows do on networks you know
what I mean so that's the power of the
future and that's the power of content
at what when I told you that I only had
channel 3 channel 5 channel 8 channel 13
then cable came and there were all these
channels on cable and then satellite
came there's all these channels on
satellite well imagine what's going to
happen when things really do go internet
and there's 2530 youtubes and there's
actual programming and it's it's it's
it's very interesting but what you said
is is the truth content is king and
owning content and having content it's
always been you know the way to go and
and you're right we bought that's why
when people say they bought the most
expensive fight library ever stupidest
statement ever made we have the biggest
fight library in the world and we have a
ton of content the great thing about our
content too is when we were you have you
guys ever seen UFC Unleashed so UFC
Unleashed will air the first one every
time that thing airs it does a million
or more viewers every time it airs
there's no programming out there like
that
as far as live sporting event goes you
see the Superbowl rearing now the
Superbowl pulls a huge number that night
that everybody watches it nobody watches
that again I'll be replaying baseball
games that happened this week
no that was bad enough to watch the
first time
I just throw that big in there oh but my
point is you know this content works and
it's its evergreen and it's it's uh it's
its stuff we're looking at for the
future question did this gentleman
trying to get in for mr. dennit
obviously a lot of the success from UFC
at least recent success came out of the
Ultimate Fighter yeah and you know you
obviously had a finale in the Bonner
Griffin fight that was one of the best
fights you ever watched and it got me
involved in the UFC and I wondered that
was an enormous marketing ploy for you
guys and I wondered if he could spend a
little bit of time talking about the
genesis of the decision to do that TV
show internally and and how you came up
with the decision to do that because
well it seems obvious in hindsight I
imagine it probably wasn't yeah so so
for those of you that don't don't know
what he's talking about when we first
bought this company we were burning cash
we didn't get into that we bought it for
two million dollars but burned another
44 million before the thing took off so
you start to get to the point where you
know when do we pull the plug on this
thing is this thing going to work what
we wanted to do is get live fights on
free TV but nobody would do it nobody
would put the UFC live on TV because
they were too worried about what might
happen you know putting old tape fights
on you know what's going to happen you
know that you know they weren't afraid
of that everybody was too afraid that's
the other thing in the television
business if you ever noticed like
American Idol will come out and then
there's five other singing shows you
know this one will come out and then
there's five other shows like that
nobody has any balls on television man
none of these guys do it's the me to
thing they all copy what everybody else
does instead of being an original you
know nobody's original you don't find
even if you look at the movies these
days everybody's remaking movies Red
Dawn this one that one they're remaking
all these movies is no real creative
talent out there right now it really
isn't and so we were trying to put the
live fights on free TV and if they just
wasn't working we couldn't get it done
so reality was huge when we launched the
first season the Ultimate Fighter was
just taken off it was everybody was
watching it was big and we said we need
to come up with a reality show and we
decided you know let's come up with a
show literally me and my team went into
my office at like 8 o'clock at night and
came out around 3:00 or 4:00 in the
morning with the Ultimate Fighter and we
bounced a zillion different concepts
around and that's the one we we came up
with
so we basically we wanted it to be our
Trojan horse because all these guys live
in a house they trained together but at
the end of every episode there's a live
fight you know what I mean there was a
fight that would be on TV and it would
end with a finale two guys fight in the
finale one guy becomes the open fighter
and gets a contract with the UFC so we
go out and start pitching this thing and
nobody wants it so yeah we call it the
idea this is how we get on TV but not if
nobody wants it so we ended up telling
we Spike TV had just come out and they
were they were calling themselves the
men's Network and we went to them and
said pitch it to him they didn't want
him we said well what if we pay for it I
said well we liked it a lot better now
so we paid ten million dollars for the
first season of The Ultimate Fighter
aired it and literally had no
advertising we spent ten million we
weren't advertising the thing you know
what I mean and even if you look at it
to get a show out there like that you
have to spend you would believe it or
not but when you see these shows that
are being marketed you know it's
anywhere from from ten to thirteen
million dollars to advertise these shows
so if you spend a million bucks might as
well just throw it off the roof you'd
have more fun than spending it so we
just put it on the air the first episode
pulled 1.3 million viewers which was by
far the biggest thing they had on their
network but didn't anybody watch season
1 of The Ultimate Fighter in here so you
remember when the whole Bobby Southworth
Chris Leben Josh Koscheck thing happened
when that whole thing went down
we pulled 2.3 million viewers which is
astronomical it's a huge especially this
thing comes out of nowhere right well at
that time when you see these shows that
starts at like duck dynasty Kitty booboo
whatever her name is you know I'm
talking about right what's her name
honey boo boo honey boo boo Yeah right
I've never seen that show of my life
but I know it you know I know it because
when a show starts to click like that
they start throwing money at it you
can't get away from it you know you
can't get away to me shows they market
like crazy to try to pull new viewers in
and how much spike spent and not a dime
I was waiting for this whole you know
when's this going to roll out so halfway
through the season the president of the
company gets fired right they had bid
all these promises to me and everything
else all dead
nothing so we go through this whole
season it's unbelievably successful and
we honestly didn't know if we were going
to have a second season so we're at the
finale that night and Diego Sanchez
fought Kenny Florian comes out and
annihilates them in a minute I'm like oh
my god this is a nightmare then force
the staff and come out and put on that
war that you talked about
and you just knew in the building that
night you just yeah I knew that was it
any doubt I had everything was gone I
knew it was going to happen and
literally the guys from spike went out
and cut the deal for the next season
with us in the alley that night I know
that sounds dramatic but it's true took
us out in the alley and cut the new deal
for the next season of The Ultimate
Fighter so if that first season didn't
happen I would not be sitting here right
now it's fact folks we are unfortunately
out of time so please join me in
thanking mr. dinowitz
thank you so much pleasure all right
thank you so much thank you share it out
thank you very much I appreciate it